welcome to this video playing webmaster
I'll go koi from the Philippines yeah
wow that must be the highest score i
have against the GM on the ICC five
point five out of six and it's not bad
this is not great yeah people nowadays
know this line oh that is a rare move
maybe this sense to avoid the capture
let's do this just going for a quickie
for okay if he takes with the Queenie
for this be five no ok this one I still
going to do that even though I have to
go to d3 if he goes 9 p-6 Knight b6 is
up it's not very good anyway I guess see
going for nor cannot do the mini can
check on edge forward bishop f2s is fine
so let's just a complete development the
reason why I think why does a little bit
better it's the bishop on age 5 and
whites better center but black doesn't
have any weakness so quite often um
there's really not that much going on 5
is interesting usually white welcomes
this make that a huge deal but I really
don't mind that he opens up the center
for me
ok I'm just going to hand Castle you
have to do that anyway TX Queen takes
Bishop c5 s maybe a line no
let's try to double him yeah yeah yeah
he's got Bishop f4 if I take if I take
him with the bishop rocky it's not a
huge problem it's not what I wanted but
ok then then he's got the cream move as
well you could croon edge for what am I
playing hear that wow really play badly
him I don't want him to escape like that
so easy Queen age 43 and he can at least
force that draw with Bishop d3 as but
it's not doing that k ab Bishop c5 is
kind of kind of annoying really maybe we
have to go here back to the one to get
better protection or default I think
maybe I mean green edge for was
certainly okay for him
and looking forward for vanity that
looks really wrong here i played this
really rebellion
I don't you can just play be five I
think Quincy to after wise Queen if five
no I now rook tea for up to 48 I mean
and I'm losing I think yeah wow really
really terrible actually considering
that this opening but with Bishop to h5
and solace is really not good it's
something that i should actually i
should get a serious advantage after
that
Kim right reason why it was said was
really really bad now this is something
where white is just comfortable after
you go see five I must be must be better
and quite substantially better actually
this is it's just enter positional
bishop on age five and e5 is just bad so
what not root you one but long castles
and ya didn't really believe in that so
much right it's very good for wider
nappy the quiz 91 good as well I don't
believe it really this and this and now
we had the next through this is just
talked to root the two it's just totally
bad this is just really bad the engine
wants to play d 5 with with an advantage
like 0.5 something but I thought Knight
b6 shouldn't be that bad yeah now can
the computer wants to win a pawn now am
but this is kind of a I don't believe it
really that this is so brilliant and it
gives my dear advantage but yeah I mean
black sister has that bad bishop now but
this is just very good so it's probably
what I mean this is now just bad huh and
it's just bad King edge one King edge
one still saves the day here this is why
didn't I mean here so that having some
kind of trouble why don't I go King edge
one there was just some bad off game
yeah this is really much better thing is
ok on b1 and you're really quicker this
is what the engine is giving Queenie
seven and then g4 and age form yeah this
is a problem why I thought that is the
anti position I hear you have the bishop
offside and them white is also better in
the center and stiff that's difficult to
play I didn't really think of long
castling him that was a bad bad miss
plane because I don't need to lose like
this that was really miserable moved
into gyro t2 and the entrance d5 I don't
really like that much is something like
that
now this is not that much I mean still
not good but it's just all the rest of
black's pieces i canna became so it
shouldn't be in any danger ready ok
thanks for watching